just hours after uber ceo travis
kalanick tweeted that tracking
journalists is not part of the company's
values and ideals there's a new
allegation this time buzzfeed says one
of its reporters was tracked by uber new
york gm josh moore by the ride-sharing
app's god view quote-unquote technology
which allows uber employees to see the
logs of customer activity uber sent
bloomberg this statement about godview
saying quote access to and use of data
is permitted only for legitimate
business purposes data security
specialists monitor and audit that
access on an ongoing basis violations of
this policy do result in disciplinary
action including the possibility of
termination and legal action
that's one of uber's issues another is
the lingering saga involving uber
executive emil michael who said at a
dinner party last week that uber should
dig up dirt on journalists unfriendly to
the company
some uber investors including ashton
kutcher the actor appear to support that
view tweeting what is so wrong about
digging up dirt on a shady journalist
but at least publicly ceo travis
kalanick disagrees ending his 14 tweet
rant on the subject with the following i
believe folks who make mistakes can
learn from them myself included that
also goes for a meal
and last i want to apologize to
sarah lacy at sarakuda on twitter sarah
lacy editor-in-chief of pando daily the
focus of emil michael's proposed
investigation joins us now here in the
studio corey johnson our editor at large
with us as well so sarah obviously it's
been an incredible 48 hours for you i
mean more than that i first heard about
this from ben smith and you know i feel
like the story is really focused to me
and travis and emil but like let's not
forget this was said at a table full of
journalists arianna huffington michael
wolff people from business insider one
thought this was wrong
one thought this was wrong and wrote a
story under intense intimidation and
that was ben smith of buzzfeed and i
mean honestly when he called me i was on
a business trip in london and i i
stepped out to talk to him because i
have enormous respect for him and i
couldn't imagine what was so important
that he needed to talk to me immediately
and i was
i was terrified and i you know the plan
as it was described was not just to dig
up dirt i mean we're not talking about
doing a google search we're talking
about a million dollar budget a four to
six staff team to do opposition research
on me that's going through trash that's
following my kids that's vans parked
outside my house and the idea was we're
going to go at her through her family
and we're going to destroy her through
her family and we're going to do it
until she backs down and no one will
ever know that uber did this so and and
one journalist thought this was wrong so
as soon as i heard this i was terrified
but i also thought
god thank god he said it to a real
journalist because otherwise he'd be
doing it and i'd have no idea i want to
know how you're feeling right now
because you've upped your own personal
security security pando tell us what
you're doing uh well you know obviously
i don't want to deal detail too much
because the point is for my family to be
safe um i have two young kids um and
look i mean uber's view was let's hit
her at her one vulnerability her kids
and and they succeeded i'm terrified we
have had to totally redo the security of
my house um i you know have you know
personal security that with me and with
my children at all times and and here's
the important thing is right now we're
in this media firestorm about this but
emil michael has not been fired and we
see right after travis apologizes
publicly in twitter what will go away
what there's no public record of
they have their celebrity investor come
out and label me as shady oh he backs
away from it but i'm now labeled as a
shady journalist he's now done a trial
balloon of is this really such a bad
thing they're starting to shift the
narrative i mean you can see what travis
bragged about at the code conference in
may this is a political campaign they've
hired political operatives watch
scandals watch house of cards that's
what's happening so when this dies down
there's no repercussions the board's
done nothing investors are supporting it
as we've seen today
it's gonna it they're gonna either go
forward with their plan or do something
worse because the story that i did that
warranted a million-dollar smear
campaign that warranted destroying my
family got nowhere near this amount of
press got nowhere near this amount of
people saying that they were they were
going to you know take the app off their
phone
something bad is going to happen do you
think that a meal should be fired i mean
ken lara put up a post on twitter saying
that it was a public company he'd be
fired exactly no i mean i think the bare
minimum we can all agree on is that
emile michael should be fired but this
is a deep problem within the company i
mean what as i've been living this
horror for the last several days what
strikes me and you know one of the
things that bothered me about uber is
whenever we would cover these stories
about assault of female passengers and
we would call the company and ask them
they would say well she was dressed
provocatively well she was drinking it
was a classic blame and and shame the
woman psychology now imagine a woman is
attacked in an uber in a way that could
dent the company's valuation as much as
my first article did
she doesn't have the resources of
private security she can't call you guys
and come and get on tv and get her side
of the story told
i feel like this is not about me this is
about journalists this is about women
getting in their cars this is about a
company culture that thinks it can throw
money to destroy people's lives and
families in the name of a greater
valuation and it's about every single
board member and private investor
stepping back and being okay with it
people who've met my kids people who've
been at my house
in 15 years of covering the valley i've
never seen anything like this you have
to wonder if the hp pretexting scandal
came out now when journalists phone
records were tapped right would there be
any outrage
would ashton kitchen could be fine with
that as well you know digging up dirt on
political candidates this is a known
tactic of political campaigns emile
michael has spent time in washington
david plouffe obviously has a long
history in washington what should
someone like david plouffe be doing to
manage this company's reputation and how
is it different when it's you and not an
aspiring elected official
you know i mean look i'm not in the
political world for a reason like i
think it's incredibly scary um but i
mean what should he do well it depends
on what his goals are i mean if you
really did want uber to be recast as a
friendly company then you know perhaps
they should start changing some of the
executives because i don't think that
you can just you know put put a new
ribbon on that and make it look yeah
that's the phrase i was gonna say being
from the south but um
but uh you know i think it depends on
what his goals are and i think unlike um
a politician uber's not running for
office this is a company that we are
trusting with our lives people i know
people who put their children in ubers
to drive them around women are getting
in ubers very late at night and yes
sometimes they're dressed provocatively
and sometimes they've had something to
drink that's why they're calling an uber
that doesn't mean they should be
victimized and if anyone raises question
their personal life gets destroyed this
is horrifying do you think that this was
said to a group of journalists so that
all of the journalists would disseminate
the intimidation or do you think this
was just some guy shooting off his mouth
it was not a guy shooting off his mouth
i am confident of that having talked to
people at the dinner this he he
articulated a plan this was not
spur-of-the-moment conversation it was a
plan to do but i think so i think it was
i think was primarily about me i think i
was the first target because i'm a woman
and i'm high profile and they knew they
could go after my kids but but i do
think i want to
it's one of two things it's either they
were putting the journalism world on
notice
or and frankly it would work with a lot
of people they've done other
intimidation tactics not this extreme
that have worked or it was um they don't
think there's anything wrong with it and
so what are the plans that they wouldn't
brag about at a dinner that's why i have
private security right now i want to get
back to this question of on versus off
the record i mean
if indeed both parties understood this
was off the record and and who knows
what the understanding of either side
really was but if you hear something
this extreme do you break that
journalistic code yes and go take it on
the record yes i i don't understand i
mean look like we you and i bet
definitely came in like sort of the old
world of journalism i don't understand
what's happened with online media today
where journalists are confused on where
their loyalties lie and journalists
think their loyalty lies to a rich guy
that they're covering who's going to lie
to them or say something horrific and
illegal that damages someone's family's
security off the record and that that
trumps that responsibility to the reader
i want to be very clear to any source of
mind listening to this my responsibility
is to my readers it is to the users of
these services it is not to you if you
lie to me if you confess to a crime to
me off the record it will become on the
record on that note there are critics of
you who have said your coverage of uber
has been
potentially unfairly critical and more
critical than pando daily's coverage of
lyft for example mark andreessen is an
investor in pando daily andreessen
horowitz is an investor in lyft how do
you respond to that it's such a silly
allegation it's the one thing that
everyone goes back to um look shervin
piscivar is a very close friend of
travis's uh was one of the first big
backers of pando uh um
uh josh koppelman also an investor in
pando uh matt kohler from benchmark i
mean they're literally people on uber's
board that are investors in pando i mean
it's it's a it's a silly argument i
would say about you know the off the
record thing is that the the the notion
of being upset about on the record off
the record the same people would be
willing to threaten journalists but are
concerned with the sanctity of on the
record and off the record is just
threaten me in a way where it's like you
know and look there's people who say
well you go after them yes i go after
them under my name i don't get into
their personal lives i've never written
anything about their personal lives and
i do it on my name what they were gonna
do was dismantle me in a way uber's
fingerprints would never be on buzzfeed
says one of its reporters was tracked by
uber new york gm josh moore by the
company's internal god view feature
which supposedly allows uber employees
to see logs of uber customer activity
our editor at large corey johnson's
still with us what is your take on this
whole
god view thing i mean uber says look
only certain employees can see this data
it's only for legitimacy
legitimate business purposes so we as we
discovered 24 hours before they included
legitimate business purposes included
going through my garbage
and having me followed so i don't have a
lot of confidence in what uber considers
a legitimate business purpose can i let
me let me push back just a little bit
did they actually go through the plan to
go through your garbage and follow their
kids or is it just merely suggested at
the dinner um
look i
as far as i know they haven't but i
don't know okay i have no way of knowing
and do you think this is something
that's pervasive of uber's company
culture or this is a couple of employees
who are out of line
you know what i think it's somewhere
between the two i used to take uber for
a long time and for a long time you know
we've started raising questions about
this company's ethics and morality since
2012 which is one of the reasons i was
the one targeted um and i still use the
ride sharing app up until recently
because i really liked a lot of the
drivers i interacted with and i thought
even though travis kalanick is obviously
morally corrupted and has a board who
will not stand up to him i thought in
spite of that they were doing some good
in the world and i did really like some
of the things that they were doing they
said they're employing 50 000 new people
right but but at this point you know we
have all covered startups long enough to
know that culture comes from the top and
the senior executive sets a tone and
what we see over and over again when
uber gets in these pr messes they'd
never fire anyone responsible now what
message does that send if you're at the
company i get rewarded for taking more
risks that frequently involve putting
women's lives in danger this i mean look
look you have young children we all have
young children what does a
three-year-old do when they are
expressing bad behavior that doesn't get
checked doesn't get checked doesn't get
checked it escalates what's happening
now is the biggest uber scandal because
none of the other stuff has ever been
checked that's a culture so you have
uber investors and people who haven't
invested in uber who wish that they did
calling travis kalanick you know one of
the best tech ceos ever comparing him to
amazon ceo jeff bezos i mean you and i
i've talked to travis he's
very convincing he's very passionate
is is is there something wrong with his
strategy i think there is always
something wrong with no one questioning
a founder and what's happening right now
is the board and investors are terrified
of him this is the first time in silicon
valley
my time covering silicon valley i have
ever thought a company would be served
by going public immediately because i
think public market investors would not
let one person have this much power and
control unchecked but unfortunately in
silicon valley this company has gotten
so valuable so quickly and the big mega
multi-billion dollar home runs are so
rare that people simply are terrified
they will not do anything well the thing
is this company already has hit a home
run i mean they're winning the market so
you wonder why
why do they have to resort to what some
people have called look you know it's
i know the plans of what was going to be
done to my family frankly a lot of the
investors have young children i think
some of these people see travis as guy
they don't want to cross when he just
happened with hewlett-packard something
similar to this they they were concerned
about the board level or the ceo was
concerned about a leak one of the board
members talking to somebody in the press
and so they hire private investigators
to illegally pretext phone calls get the
phone records of all these reporters a
couple of them now work at bloomberg but
didn't at the time uh and go through
their garbage as well hire private
investigators to legally go through the
garbage but there was a criminal
investigation do you think there needs
to be an investigation based on what's
happened to you if anything's happening
at all i don't think uh we're at the
point of a criminal investigation yet
and i think that is solely because of
ben smith's journalism and ben smith's
conscience i am preparing for the fact
that no one has been fired no actions
have been taken and as soon as this dies
down they will come at me in this or a
worse way i'm convinced of it when it
comes to data uber certainly not the
first company to struggle with how do
they handle customer data from facebook
to google how should they handle the
data that they're getting very valuable
well you know i think that we see i mean
again the the examples of misogyny in
this company are astounding i mean
there's the whole glory rides thing
where they were tracking um by looking
at the data patterns who was having one
night stands and you know fist bumping
and high fiving people virtually over
this i mean this is a company that
clearly is not just looking at customer
data in order to route cars more
effectively and when you talk about the
sort of data they have on you they're
making assumptions of are you sleeping
with someone based on your patterns um
it's really quite scary
well in terms of the privacy i mean you
know you can imagine how young companies
struggle with these things is there a
point at which we've seen this with
other companies where privacy matters
you know because we're in a different
era now where we're mobile phones and
and people are getting types of data
that they never could before does there
need to be a different kind of privacy
for all the companies that are in this
arena look i mean this story is
fascinating because it is a litmus test
for silicon valley investors and do they
have a conscience over money it is a
litmus test for journalists and will
they stand up and say you cannot
dismantle us and does the first
amendment matter and it is also a litmus
test for the public you know in the past
people have voted with their feet when
it comes to facebook or google when it
comes to privacy but uber is very
different because it's the real world
you're getting in people's cars is that
finally scary enough that it changes
consumer behavior and also uber unlike
facebook there are other alternatives i
mean at the end of the day i don't know
about you guys but when i take any of
the ride sharing services in san
francisco they have two to three phones
on the dash because they're driving all
of these services
well um you know i should point out like
as frightening as this is and and i've
been through this myself in different
ways from investors not from companies
but
you know there are journalists out there
in jails in iraq or in iran there are
journalists covering isis who are scared
to death and have faced actual death
threats every day it's on a different
level we i think we should acknowledge
that at the very least i think that's
true but frankly if you're a mother and
um they're threats made against your
children that's do you think it's hard
to imagine what are you really
made against
based on what i've heard and based of
what i know of this company i'm
convinced about that
it's frightening stuff yeah
it's it's easy to be a tough journalist
and write the stories and push them out
and then and but not sort of get that
involvement but i think you know
attaching kushner's comment i mean
ashton kushner was saying on twitter
this morning emily sent it out this
morning to us and and
saying why shouldn't journalists be held
to the same standard i think that it's
not really about that i mean what we do
we should absolutely be held to stand
but also what is the same thing i mean
this is how they're trying to reframe it
they shouldn't go through his trials
very careful for us to actually hold
them to what they said and not allow
them to twist what they said emil
michael said give me a taste of my own
medicine well i've never gone through
these people's trash i've never followed
their kids i've never hired on a million
dollar budget a team of opposition
researchers to go with their family
industry well let's be clear they didn't
it's not clear that they actually no but
the plan was to give me a taste of my
own medicine along those lines and and
uber uber spokesperson has said we do
not do this we do not invest why haven't
you fired that's not our policy why
haven't they fired him
if his views didn't first of all if
what he said doesn't represent who's his
views whose views do they represent they
came out of his mouth he's not denying
that and if it if they are horrified if
they found these comments inhuman why
haven't they fired him now this is just
one person that said this right
is it do you think this do do you know
this goes beyond that i mean speaking of
travis for example um i i definitely
know secondhand accounts i mean i've not
had anyone say it to me
and do you think travis was at this this
dinner
travis was he was
at this dinner but my question is what
was heard who heard
what emil michael said aside from ben
smith and look i was we don't know the
bottom line is we don't i wasn't there i
know travis very well i think what
concerns me is i also know several of
the board members and investors very
well and i emailed them as soon as ben
smith's story come out and i'll name
some of them shervin piscivar rob hayes
from first round bill gurley from
benchmark and i said i need to know do
you support this company using a million
dollars of your money to smear me not a
single one has even called me back or
emailed
fascinating it's amazing stuff it's
amazing also the lessons from
hewlett-packard you know because a lot
of people were still around it wasn't
that long ago it was ten years ago yeah
and it's amazing that those lessons
weren't learned about why that's bad
it's also interesting to me that that
these business executives don't seem to
appreciate the role of journalism and
why journalism makes their businesses
better makes their society better
helps their companies start to get some
attention when they come up with these
great ideas would you know look whatever
might
here's a question you know travis said
executives and pete every anyone can can
and should be given the opportunity to
learn from their mistakes should any of
this be forgiven
no i mean i mean no you have to earn
forgiveness
you have to earn forgiveness
and the apology i mean have you seen
there's no actions
there's no act no one has been fired and
today you see again political strategy
101 a celebrity investor who has a
higher profile than anyone coming out
calling me a shady journalist the same
thing they do when women drivers say
they've been attacked in their cars
attack my character they are doing the
same playbook they outlined i thought it
was telling that in travis's uh
twitter sort of uh blast that he used
the word folks which is a word that
president obama seems to use
uncomfortably as well when he's trying
to seem like regular people
a lot of people noted that he think he
apologized to me at the end do you think
any of this is going to matter to
customers
does this affect their business i hope
so because i think that's frankly the
only hope because we've seen investors
won't act
all right you know i do want to add that
we did reach out to uber and ask them if
they wanted to have a voice in this
conversation and they did give us
those statements